[Applause]
for a game so concerned with the perils
of futurism it's ironic that prey feels
like it's trapped in the past
it takes inspiration from immersive Sims
like System Shock deus ex and Bioshock
but while these titles take ideas
underpinning the genre and push them
forward
praise humdrum execution of the
fundamentals leave it feeling stuck in
time set in the year 2025 prey cosplays
as Morgan you a scientist that finds
herself or himself trapped on tellus won
a space station overrun by a race of
highly intelligent aliens called the
typhoon
praise opening is its most memorable
part largely due to its own would you
kindly moment and the promise of what it
could mean
praise early game twist lays the
groundwork for players to scrutinize
their agency question the motivations of
characters and reevaluate the impact
they're having it's an opportunity to
tell a twisting paranoia filled story
that forces you to second-guess your own
character but that opportunity is
largely wasted prey quickly loosens its
grip on this narrative thread allowing
you to drift into the background in
favor of environmental storytelling that
shifts the focus to tell us one itself
with its fusion of art deco stylings and
practical design tell us one is
initially very striking but it's
consistent aesthetic throughout is
broken only by one standout area
otherwise the place is comprised of
typical living cores
office areas and science labs logically
I can appreciate that the lack of
variety makes sense it's an institution
designed to house people that do science
not a funfair nevertheless the lack of
variety doesn't provide much incentive
to stop and admire surroundings beyond
the initial few hours good immersive
Sims like Bioshock and designed weave
stories into their environments telling
micro stories in the process but in prey
those stories are limited to the
uninteresting a spacestation ruined by a
catastrophic event and the hubris of its
leaders is evocative in itself but pray
never colors in the outline of these
events making the world feel like it
lacks depth smaller tales involving the
people stationed on tellus one can be
found by reading emails at computer
terminals and although they provide a
little more to latch on to by and large
is all fairly forgettable there's the
occasional meaningful exchange but the
abundance of mundane knows between
colleagues makes reading them a chore
and overall they feel like filler for an
overarching narrative that stretched
thin a key part of prey story involves
presenting conflicting evidence about
Morgan's personally before the memory
loss specifically her intent for tellus
one and her contingency for a typhoon
outbreak the game wants you to define
your Morgan but only serves up a handful
of moments to invite you to do so these
come in the form of uninspired missions
for characters who come off as
distractions from the main narrative
instead of pivotal figures in the story
he makes an honest effort of raising the
profile of these people by app and is
late in the game and when all said and
done the characters didn't really speak
to me there's a restraint to pray that
creates a disquieting quality in tell us
one but when this philosophy is extended
to his characters it just makes them
fade away
can be blamed for thinking about
ignoring a guy that wants you to go out
of your way to fetch a personal I effect
or a lady who asks you to spend precious
resources in battling typhoon to grab
her some medicine it turns out however
these menial tasks are critical to the
ending and when the game later the
unexpected way it's all tied together
the revelation didn't feel earned pray
does occasionally deliver an engagement
mission but they're few and far in
between
praise gameplay experience fares better
but it's uneven and at times the systems
feel at odds with themselves with
limited access to weapons and special
abilities much of the early game feels
like a slog it's like the worst parts of
a survival horror a punishing war of
attrition but without the cycle of
tension and release that makes it
enjoyable this becomes more pronounced
when you consider that mimics the most
prevalent type of typhoon enemy in the
early stages have a tendency of
appearing in blind spots and catching
you off god this aspect of the game is
both exhilarating and infuriating the
mimics are small highly mobile creatures
that can shape-shift into innocuous
objects around them all this was
effective in creating tension I felt
they also detracted from exploration I
wasn't soaking in the atmosphere as much
as I was painstakingly scouring it to
find that mimic before it chips away at
my health and when I took on the mimics
the lethargic controls of gunplay
coupled with the small black spider
darting around the floor dimly lit room
and leaping off walls made me feel more
like mr. bean I also felt forced to play
conservatively for most of the game the
scarcity of health packs and ammunition
meant it was in my best interest to
sneak by enemies which goes against
preys claim that you can play your way
and became frustrating when enemies
swarmed around objectives as the game
progresses however neuro mods become
more abundant which in turn means that
you can unlock abilities that level the
playing field somewhat this is one
praised combat opens up and while it
doesn't provide as much room for
creativity as Dishonored 2 weapon and
abili combinations develop a satisfying
synergy some powers allow you to take
control of enemies to fight alongside
you for a short period of time or
teleport you short distances to get the
jump on enemies as new foals are
introduced it becomes imperative to use
the psycho scope a helmet with a scanner
on it to research the typhoon and reveal
their individual weaknesses while also
unearthing more ability to unlock the
downside of using alien powers is that
turrets littered around talisman
identify you as being part - and open
fire on you again early on this feels
like punishment for trying to explore
the more interesting wrinkles of combat
but with time tourists also become less
of an issue as they can be hacked or
easily destroyed
in its later stages praise combat feels
varied and strategic you also gain the
ability to break down and reassemble
junk into useful items ranging from
weaponry and neuro mod upgrades to
turrets and med packs having this
ability ease the lack of resources and
empowered me to really approach combat
and exploration how I wanted I could go
into any scenario feeling like I had a
decent shot of defeating the - and
achieving my objective neuro mods can
also be used to solve preys puzzles
which mostly involve figuring out how to
gain entry into inaccessible locations
while not challenging these puzzles
shine a spotlight on the layout of Talas
by allowing you a degree of freedom in
how you approach them on a small scale
looping vents multi-layered rooms and
gravity lifts that act as arteries
throughout the station show
consideration has been given to the
physical construction of Telus 1 the
glue cannon is particularly effective in
showing how praised environments can
fold in on themselves it's phone can be
launched at walls and when it hardens
Morgan can use it as a makeshift
platform this makes it possible to
circumvent the obvious path in favour of
a more diverse approach highlighting the
thoughtful level design
unfortunately I encountered a number of
technical issues with pray in my
playthrough the most severe of which
prevented quest progression entirely
these had to be resolved by loading and
earlier safe which meant losing some
progress pray also suffers from lengthy
load times when moving between areas and
characters frequently clip through walls
resulting in an overall experience that
feels rough
[Music]
prey is a game of uneven pacing and
uninteresting characters it opens with a
poignant thought-provoking premises but
fails to follow through until the end
when it claims a revelation it doesn't
quite earn its gameplay follows out of
the gate but eventually matures into
something worthwhile if a bit familiar
as an homage to System Shock its
competent and at times even enjoyable
however prey fails to distinguish itself
and next to immersive sim contemporaries
such as Dishonored it feels stagnant
[Music]
you